bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur e rt france claude georges maison
alors on vient d'entendre et d'écouter
ursula von der leyen emmanuel macron qui
parle est un bien évidemment de ce qui
se passe actuellement au kazakhstan quel
est réellement la marche la marge de
manoeuvre de l'union européenne sur ce
dossier
sur ce dossier la marge et est très
faible et je crois que le président et
ben ali ont été interpellés par un
journaliste à la conférence de presse
sur ce sujet donc ils ont dû répondre
est en effet ils ont répondu ce que
disait déjà les communiqués de la
journée d'hier à savoir que l'un et
l'autre on appelle à la désescalade et
souhaite que les choses se passent pas
dans la violence mais par la négociation
mais cette visite en réalité et une
visite de routine chez les cellules âge
au début de chaque présidence
semestrielle la commission dans son
ensemble collège des 29 commissaire se
déplacent dans la capitale du pays qui
va exercer la présidence pendant six
mois et
pour des raisons que j'ignore on leur a
proposé ce matin de se rendre au
panthéon peut-être pour y chercher
l'inspiration
puisque jean monnet quand inspirateur de
l'europe des années 50 y est y étaient
inhumés et que simone veil aussi qui a
joué un rôle comme présidente du
parlement européen y est inhumé et puis
ensuite chaque mais chaque commissaire
discute avec ses ministres qui sont ses
homologues mais des finances mais des
transports ministre de l'agriculture et
puis madame an der leyen a discuté avec
le président macron et c'est donc ce
matin
ce qui s'est passé avec la conférence de
presse donc vous avez montré vous le
disais un peu de punch maison est vide
routine il m'a nui dames on se rappelle
la france a pris la présidence de
l'union européenne pendant six mois mais
il a également été question du dossier
craignant on a l'impression que ce
dossier
prend une place très importante à chaque
fois qu'il ya des réunions
internationales et la ursula von der
leyen a dit je vais la cité 1 quelle que
soit la solution elle doit passer par
l'europe qu'est ce que ça veut dire
alors là aussi c'était en réponse à une
question d'un journaliste et effectuer
la question était un peu insidieuse elle
était elle commencer par le fait que le
président baden et le président pauthe
il allait parler le haut par un parent
représentant interposés à genève le 9
janvier prochain deux des questions de
sécurité en europe et parmi les
questions de sécurité il ya
naturellement l'ukraine alors
effectivement la question était est ce
que l'europe est absente de cette
discussion et
monsieur macron que madame l'aliène on
dit mais il peut pas y avoir de
discussion conclusive sur la sécurité en
europe sans les européens donc il faudra
bien que d'une manière ou d'une autre
les européens à reprennent la main dans
cette effusion c'est une bonne chose
qu'il y ait des discussions bilatérales
entre les américains et les russes mais
il faudra bien abandonné que les
amériques que les européens reprennent
leur place puisqu'ils sont concernés au
premier chef ils sont déjà concernés par
des sujets stratégiques lorsque donald
trump est sortie du traité sur les
forces nucléaires intermédiaire il a en
effet gravement affecter la stabilité de
l'europe puisque ses forces nucléaires
intermédiaires ont une portée tels que
elle tomberait sur les pays européens
mais par ailleurs il ya en effet
l'ukraine comme vous le dites et
monsieur mâcon comme madame renarde et
elles ont rappelé que le format européen
pour discuter du sujet et elle forma
normandie avec l'allemagne la france
le représentant de l'union européenne
pour les questions de politique
étrangère
l'ouest c'est eux
la russie et l'ukraine et que par
conséquent un moment ou un autre ce
format normandie devrait
reprendre ses discussions
macro supa crew a également dit que il
restait partisans comme il l'avait été
avec madame merkel d'un dialogue avec la
russie dialogue bilatéral qui existe il
a dit je parle fréquemment au président
poutine au téléphone des sujets de
sécurité bien entendu mais aussi de
manière collective un dialogue entre
l'union européenne et la russie qui est
prévu d'ailleurs par par les traités
donc un peu dialogue tous azimuts et en
effet l'ukraine dans cette affaire se
trouve un petit peu comme un enjeu dans
ces discussions entre les super grand ou
dans le format normandie alors que le
nonce maison en très rapidement on est
pressé par le temps suis désolé donc la
france un qui va prendre pendant six
mois en la présence tournante de l'union
européenne emmanuel macron la d1 et les
cités d'europe et il s'agit en tout cas
de rendre l'europe puissance dans le
monde tellement souveraine est libre de
ses choix et maître de son destin
est ce que c'est encore le cas il ya ce
que même ça a déjà été le cas
alors c'est très ambitieux bien entendu
mais si on regarde les choses calmement
l'europe a réussi son intégration
économique
jusqu'à d'ailleurs la constitution d'une
zone d'une zone euro qui vient de fêter
ses 27 années de fonctionnement et qui
semble depuis la crise grecque depuis la
crise italienne qui semble irréversible
d'ailleurs les grands pays dans le bon
détiennent une partie de leurs réserves
monétaires en euros donc sur le plan
économique
l'europe est déjà une europe puissance
mais elle ne l'est pas sur le plan
politique et c'est cela que c'est à cela
que monsieur macron voudrait s'attaquer
puisque je souhaite un vieux sujet
d'ailleurs à la diplomatie française
mais que monsieur macron remet au goût
du jour
transformer l'europe en europe puissance
sur d'autres sujets alors il ya des
sujets sur lesquels on voit bien comment
c'est possible qu'ils qui relève aussi
de l'économie les problèmes industriels
est en effet l'autonomie technologique
de l'europe la révolution numérique
c'est tout à fait possible que l'europe
reprennent là aussi son destin en main
sur le plan sur ces plans des nouvelles
technologies ça sera un peu plus
difficile dans le domaine de l'industrie
de l'armement certains pays européens
ont une industrie de l'armement
puissante il ya des coopérations elles
sont limitées et les américains
naturellement à travers l'otan font en
sorte que les pays européens achètent
beaucoup l'armement aux états unis et
puis à ce qu'il a vu dans votre sujet la
fameuse boussole stratégique que madame
van der leyen a aussi appelé un livre
blanc sur la stratégie européenne
il y sera discuté il ya déjà une
proposition de la commission qui est sur
la table et qui sera discutée lors d'un
conseil européen d'aidé au sommet au
mois de mars bien sûr
quelques mois six mois mais en réalité
beaucoup moins à cause de l'élection
présidentielle qui neutralisera la fin
du semestre et bien c'est très court et
c'est très court pour faire aboutir les
idées comme l'idée de l'europe puissance
politique et encore plus l'idée de
l'europe puissance militaire mais au
niveau des concepts des progrès ont été
faits et il est possible que le sujet
progresse par ailleurs évidemment
monsieur macron attache une importance
capitale à ce que le système de schengen
soit réformée à ce qu'il y ait une
nouvelle gouvernance qui soit donnée à
la zone schengen qui sera calqué à peu
près sûr celle de la zone euro
c'est-à-dire une réunion de ministres
des 27 états membres qui s'ajouteraient
aux systèmes institutionnels de schengen
actuelle qui est un petit peu trop
administratif pour ne pas dire
eurocratique
l'ours maison merci beaucoup pour votre
éclairage en tout cas je rappelle que
vous êtes expert en relations
internationales mercière